best thing for kids when when  um when they are young growing up is to  have a healthy loving relationship being  shown in front of them if you two are  not getting on as a married couple at  least separate but keep the love or in  for the child because at the end of the  day it's not about you and the person  being together about that kid growing up  healthy with mental and emotional  stability along why can't you just live  in separate rooms live in separate  houses why because living in separate  rooms well I want it's better for the  kids to have two parents in the home you  know what I genuinely but see this is  like a modern mindset where it's like me  me me first my happiness first before my  own children and like that I think  that's why we have like a very [ __ ] up  society today because it's me me my  happiness me